what up space fam Golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss one
piece in this time to specifically talk
about some truly insane and hype
spoilers where awaken gear 5 Luffy makes
his return in Epic fashion where we get
huge news about Lucci's new powers and
even akinu and kizaru are in it so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
want to see more spoiler videos like
this one chill parking within and smash
that like button until the fireworks go
off be a smashing pirate king rather
than passing Orochi and the universe
will reward you make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
if you haven't already to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and also
while you wait for the chapters to drop
and for the spoilers to drop you can
also check out our huge and growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all yonko Warlords all zones an
hour-long video on Shanks and much more
link to that is in the description and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all we are discussing of
course chapter 1000 and 69 today well
last time on chapter 1068 we left off at
Luchi turning into his leopard hybrid
form and one hit koing Atlas so Oda was
hyping him up a bit before he runs into
Luffy and then when Luchi notices Luffy
he says straw hat and then Luffy
responds hilariously pigeon guy as I was
mentioning in the last review I really
like that antagonist like Luchi get
promotions and get stronger in the world
of One Piece it's not like just a main
group excels while the defeated
opponents stay completely stagnant or
get weaker when this happens we get cool
opportunities like this where we can not
only get to see how much stronger Luffy
got since his last fight but we also get
to see how much stronger Luchi got even
though as I was saying I don't expect
that to be anywhere near Luffy's level
and Oda definitely delivered in a way
that I hoped he would I always ask you
guys for your predictions in my chapter
reviews and like me a lot of people
thought that there is no way Luffy at
this point would have had a hard time
with Luchi we'll get into how true or
not that was but thankfully it wasn't
not quite that straightforward and
predictable let me explain there was the
hype Edition we're told of Luchi having
an Awakening now or Japan writes that it
resembles a big car with a mix of
Choppers monster point and who's whose
Zone which is a saber-toothed tiger I
remember some people in the comments
wondering and even thinking that Luffy
couldn't go gear 5 again it wasn't that
easy he couldn't do whatever he wanted
to but looks like he clearly can since
he does in this chapter and I expected
as much it wasn't one of those Goku
Ultra Instinct moments future goes in
here breaking in which I'll do every so
often with new information that's come
out since this video was sent to be
edited we're also told luchi's awakened
form is similar to his slender hybrid
form his black Furs now look like black
clouds or Flames he has black clouds or
steam floating around his neck too
similar to Luffy so this should be a
cool mirroring visually and most of us
know what to expect now from gear 5 but
we're told that the fight proceeds in
Tom and Jerry's style like the old
cartoons just like his fights with kaido
did and it's pretty perfect this time
since Lucy's a big cat just like Tom is
a cat that dwarfs Jerry the mouse in
size if you used to watch Tom and Jerry
like me when there was no anime to watch
on TV I feel like that means you gotta
hit that like button to show solidarity
I'm like 99.9 sure those are the rules
now I said the fight wasn't as
straightforward as some thought but
obviously we were still right overall
that Luffy would overwhelm Lucci and
we're even told that Lucci is terrified
by Luffy's new powers I knew that Luchi
would be shocked by them and I put as
much in the title but terrified is an
even more hype word and I can't wait to
see that look on his face Ain't No Way
Luchi is on yonko gear 5 Luffy level but
still glad we got another confirmed
awakened Zone and this one is much more
interesting than the ones at impel down
because Luchi clearly hasn't lost his
mind and become a simple-minded killing
machine in the same way to me that would
kill a lot of the Zone hype if everyone
ends up like that when they awaken I
obviously much prefer this because
despite being awakened the jail beasts
were kind of underwhelming from that
regard it's also really cool that
luchi's Awakening is a carnivorous Zone
Awakening specifically we don't talk
about that a lot but I do think
carnivorous zones are underrated we then
get even more hype details about Akainu
holding back kizaru from going to
Egghead Island so imagine that imagine
kids are just showing up that would be
crazy having these two in the chapter
alone is hype but it seems like Akainu
has been doing a lot of holding back
these days and I'm hoping it's all
explained and leading up to something
big sooner than later let me know your
thoughts is there a chance Akainu is
involved in sword and making moves
accordingly or does he just have
something really big and bad planned
soon and doesn't want anybody
prematurely ruining it obviously since
the dude took out Ace it's probably
still easier to believe that it's the
latter but I don't know Akainu is
interesting these days future goes in
here and the more complete Reddit
spoilers say that AKA Inu simply asks
for where kizuru is and the Marine
reports that kizuru is already on his
way to Egghead so we may actually get
the ziki so to confront the straw ads
and that raised the stakes and I
definitely think we're ready to face an
admiral now and I really hope he gets
there and is not stopped again since
these more complete spoilers are
definitely making this look like a more
worthwhile conflict rather than just a
short blip we're told that Luffy defeats
and Ko's Luchi future goes in here just
to say that it doesn't actually look
like the fight is over at all but I'm
not complaining especially if we
actually get kizuru to come which would
mean a much more significant conflict
than I at first expected another thing
Luchi does after he recovers from being
blown away by a new move of Luffy's
where he turns the floor into a fist is
a tax Center Maru by doing this AKA by
eliminating sento Maru the chain of
command should go to the seraphims
obeying him AKA Luchi Luffy is now the
one shocked and angry and that appears
to be where the chapter ends and there
is a break next week now we potentially
have the seraphim cp0 and kizaru at
least to deal with which actually does
seem like a pretty meaningful battle for
the crew way more than most of us
expected last we were told another hype
detail we are told that we get a bit of
lore about Devil's fruit which I assume
probably just means devil fruits in
general which is interesting too but if
by any chance it means Devil's fruit as
in a devil devil fruit that would be
insane and it would be a big fruit that
would probably run parallel to Luffy's
sun god fruit there's even been theories
about Blackbeard having a devil devil
fruit mythical Zone that I've discussed
on this channel but since this early
spoilers here it's probably just a
misprint here and I'm reading way too
much into it either way big or small I
love more juicy devil fruit secrets and
can't wait to see what it's about and if
it'll continue in the next chapter
future goes in here to say yes it was
just about devil fruits but man that's
some interesting information that we got
we're told that everything on Earth is
born out of people's wishes and the same
goes for the devil fruits as well all
ability users who bear that curse are
basically living in the future that
someone once wished for Vega Punk is
also the one to point out that the
gomugomonomi isn't in ancient texts but
Luffy looks like Nika a guy who can only
be found in ancient texts but he says
even if the name is erased from history
as long as people keep wishing for him
Nika's existence will never die that's
huge and it really seems like Oda wants
to emphasize this idea that our thoughts
and wills are powerful and can shape the
world around us more than we even know
definitely very cool that we got so much
juicy info on the devil fruits and that
is it for the spoilers for now obviously
subscribe and I'll go over the official
chapter in much more detail in my review
later on in the week so look down make
sure you're subscribed and that that
notification Bell is active that way you
joined the knock of mine won't be
missing any of the many upcoming one
piece videos we got many exciting ones
in the works right now let me know where
you think we're going from here now that
a seeming threat popped up and was
quickly dealt with what will be the
threat next will it be Blackbeard will
we save Kobe next find out on the next
episode of One Piece Z I also just want
to say it's cool that we got to see two
awakened zones going head to head this
chapter yeah it might not be a first if
my theory is right that kaido had an
awakened fruit and that would obviously
be more hype since that was then a fight
between two awakened mythical zones but
this was still cool too and since we
don't even know if kaido's was awakened
it's cool that we finally got a
confirmed to awakened zones fight if you
enjoyed and want to keep these one piece
reviews coming Channel parking within
and smash that like button until the
fireworks go off be a smashing pirate
king rather passing Orochi and the
universe will reward you while you wait
for the future chapters to drop the
future spoilers to drop and of course
the review later on in the week you can
also check out our growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all
yonko Warlords an hour-long video on
Shanks all Zone fruits and much more
linked to that is in the description and
on screen now thanks so much for
watching since I mentioned FIFA in the
last video I'll also just say very sorry
to see Japan not make history and lose
in the round of 16. would have been
really cool if they made history but oh
well there's always the future and
they've been doing really well lately
good for them and until next next time
see you Space Cowboys